Hello everyone.
My name is Paul and I'm from Canada.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today we'll be going way back to see how
we're all connected.
Well,
not all of us,
but about half of us.
Around 46% of the people on Earth speak
an Indo European language as their
native language throughout Europe,
South Asia,
the Americas and beyond.
The Indo European language family
contains languages as diverse as
English,
Hindi,
Persian,
Russian,
Armenian,
and Greek languages,
which on the surface may seem to have
nothing in common,
but they actually do all Indo European
languages developed from Prodo Indo
European.
According to the most widely accepted
theory prodo Indo European was spoken
around 6,500
years ago on the Eurasian Steppe of
eastern Ukraine,
southern Russia,
and the Caucasus.
The Indo Europeans were the first or
among the first people to domesticate
horses,
which greatly increased their ability to
travel and migrate over the following
three Millennia.
Indo European people migrated far and
wide,
conquering new lands on horseback and
bringing their language with them as it
developed into different varieties,
which eventually grew into different
branches of the Indo European language
family.
The Indo Europeans first migrated into
Europe,
Anatolia,
and Central Asia.
Then later into northern India and Iran.
As migration continued deeper into
Europe and Central Asia.
There's an alternate theory based more
on archeological evidence that suggests
that the Indo European languages began
in Anatolia several thousand years
earlier and spread with the expansion of
agriculture.
There are no written records of Prodo
Indo European and it's early offshoots,
so the best we can do is to theorize and
imagine.
However they happened to take place
during these migrations,
Prodo Indo European split into numerous
different languages which would
gradually developed into entire branches
of the Indo European language family.
Those branches are and a Anatolian,
which is now extinct,
tow Korean,
which is also extinct Italia and Celtic,
which may share a common he tello,
Celtic ancestor,
Armenian and Albanian,
which each consists of just one language
as far as we know,
Hellenic Germanic,
Balto,
Slavic,
which split into the Baltic and Slavic
branches and into Iranian,
which split into the ironic and indic
branches.
All of these branches and their
individual languages have been
developing in different regions with
different influences for thousands of
years,
so they are now very different from each
other,
but through comparative study we can see
that Indo European languages share a
common word stock as well as some
phonetic.
Again,
historically speaking,
some grammatical tendencies.
There are a significant number of
cognitive words in Indo European
languages.
By the way,
the word cognate comes from Latin
[inaudible],
which means born together.
These words were indeed born together in
Prato Indo Europeans,
and if we're aware of the sound changes
that have taken place,
we can identify cognates.
For instance,
the word meaning bear or carry.
In Sanskrit,
it's the hod.
In Greek,
it's pad.
In modern Greek.
This might be pronounced like an f
sound,
but in ancient Greek it was actually an
aspirated pup sound.
In Latin,
it's fed in Gothic,
it's by it.
In old English,
it's bad.
They all come from Prodo Indo European
by head,
and my pronunciation of these different
languages is probably not perfect,
but I'm just giving it a shot myself.
I should point out that the Prodo Indo
European words are theoretical
reconstructions and that there's no way
of knowing for sure what they sounded
like,
but these words here are fairly
recognizable.
Some are a little less recognizable.
In English,
we have the word work,
which comes from old English.
We had a,
and in modern Greek,
the word for work is edit goal,
which was Aragon in ancient Greek and in
some texts there was an alternate form
whether gone,
they both stem from the pro Indo
European word,
wedding film Indo European languages can
be divided into two classes,
the chem tomb languages and the sultan
languages.
[inaudible] is the word for 100 in
Avastin,
an ancient Iranian language.
Centum is the word for 100 in Latin.
These two words illustrate a sound shift
that occurred in Indo European
languages.
Prodo Indo European had a palatalized k
sound that was distinct from the regular
vilar k sound,
a palatalized consonant sounds kind of
like it's followed by a y sound like
cure as opposed to cook in the Septum
languages.
This palatalized sound remained a
separate phoneme from cup and it became
a civil and sound like a sub or a show.
So the Prodo Indo European word for 100
cutone became Chatam in Sanskrit,
Shim Taz in Lithuanian,
and in many Slavic languages.
It's stole.
These words have all developed and
diverged quite a bit.
But if you're aware of the sound shift
from a k sound to an s sound,
you can recognize these cognates more
easily in the Ken tomb languages.
The twoK sounds merged together,
or in the case of the dramatic branch
shifted to an h sound.
So cute.
Tome became centum in Latin and hey
catone in Greek cunt in Welsh and honed
in old English.
So let's take a look at these two words.
In English hundred and sent,
we usually think of hundred as a native
Germanic word and sent as a lone word
from Latin,
but these are actually cognitive.
First,
let's take away the ending of the word
ribbed,
which comes from a suffix,
meaning count or number that let's
change the h back to a k and now you can
kind of see the resemblance.
See the resemblance.
Remember that the sea in insent was
originally pronounced like a k,
Cook and Latin.
Also,
remember that d is the voice equivalent
of tea,
so you can often see these sounds
alternating and related languages.
Some core words have been preserved in
many or even all Indo European
languages.
These include some animals.
For example,
Prodo Indo,
European equals.
This means horse.
You know that equestrian animal in
Latin,
it's equis.
In ancient Greek,
it was keep us.
In Sanskrit,
it's Ashford and in Persian it's aspect.
The Latin and Greek examples are to him
examples,
but in Greek it seems that the k sound
assimilated to the pcaob next to it.
The Sanskrit in Persian examples are
sought them.
Examples,
since you can see that the k sound
became shuck and suck,
it also seems that the w sound shifted
to a v sounded Sanskrit and to uh,
be sound in Persian and those are sound
changes that take place frequently in
various different languages.
Other frequent cognates include the
numbers from one to 10 words referring
to family members,
agricultural words and various natural
phenomena like the words for tree and
wood in Prodo Indo European Dodo or Dre,
you in old English today,
Ale in Gothic put a u in ancient Greek
Dota,
which actually meant spear in Sanskrit
Daadab in old church slavonic don't
evolve in Armenian zod this shared
vocabulary.
It might be hard to spot when you're not
looking for it,
but when you start to notice the sounds
that commonly alternate in those
cognates,
for example,
the voiceless t and the voice deep,
then cognit start to be more obvious.
Indo European languages have developed
so far from pro Indo European that
grammatically they are very diverse and
they have many features that other Indo
European languages don't share.
But because Prodo Indo European was a
highly inflected language,
all of its descendants are inflected
language is to some extent by
inflection,
I mean that words change form to reflect
grammatical functions like number
person,
tense mood case.
One example is the verb endings we find
in various Indo European languages in
Prodo Indo European,
the reconstructed singular forms for the
verb to bear our pedal or the head of
me,
the head of seat,
that a t and in Sanskrit the had Ami
Darcy Bahati in Latin Fedele fetis fed
it in old English better or Bentyl
biddies biddies in many languages,
including English.
These inflections have been lost to a
large extent.
In modern English,
we only retained the third person
inflection.
He bears or she bears,
but English still had the second person
inflection until the early modern
English period.
So if you read a King James Bible,
you'll see the sentence,
thou barest record of myself.
This is the second person form and val
means you cases pro Indo European nouns
had inflections for eight grammatical
cases.
Sanskrit maintained all eight cases and
so did the ancient Iranian language of
Estin Latin retained six cases and old
English had for modern English.
Nounce do not have case endings and
that's also true for many other Indo
European languages like most of the
romance languages,
when language is no longer have case
inflections,
the function of nouns is indicated more
by word order and by the use of
prepositions.
But many modern Indo European languages
do have numerous cases like most Balto,
Slavic languages,
which have six to eight cases,
German and Icelandic,
which have four cases and modern Greek,
which also has four.
So the connection between the modern
Indo European languages may not be
obvious,
but when we look back historically at
how those languages have developed and
the different stages of those languages,
we can find more connections.
The question of the day,
if you speak in Indo European language,
did you discover any new connections
between your language and others during
this video?
Let us know in the comments down below.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and Instagram,
and thank you to all of my fantastic
patrion supporters,
especially these wonderful people right
here on the screen.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.
Yeah.